you are a genius if you can solve this  or so they say let the four boxes be  represented by the variables a b c and d  the puzzle translates mathematically  into four equations a plus b is equal to  eight a plus c is equal to thirteen C  minus D is equal to six and B plus d is  equal to eight to solve this system of  equations we add the third and fourth  equations to eliminate the D variable  giving C plus b is equal to 14. then  from the difference of the first two  equations we eliminate the a variable  giving C minus B is equal to five we  take the two resulting equations and  then add them together to eliminate the  B variable this gives two c is equal to  19 or C is equal to 9.5 having solved  for one of the variables we can easily  solve for all of the others a plus 9.5  is equal to 13 meaning a is equal to 3.5  then 3.5 plus b is equal to eight so B  is equal to 4.5 and finally 4.5 plus d  is equal to 8 meaning that D is also  equal to 3.5 and that's the answer